- [Announcer] This program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learned?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
- Good afternoon everyone.
I'm Mary Comerio, professor
of the graduate school
in the College of Environmental Design,
and chair of the Hitchcock
Professorship Committee.
We are pleased, along
with the graduate council,
to present Lucy Jones, this year's speaker
in the Charles M. and Martha
Hitchcock lecture series.
Dr. Lucy Jones has
served as a seismologist
with the U.S. Geological Survey
and a visiting research associate
at the seismological laboratory
at Cal Tech since 1983.
She created the Science
Applications for Risk Reduction,
SAFRR, project to innovate and protect
safety, security, and economic
well-being of the nation.
One of the major projects of this
is a shakeout earthquake scenario
and a sort of public
emergency preparedness event
that began with five million people
in Southern California in 2008,
and has expanded to more than
24 million people around the world.
Now, let me tell you, Lucy got up
at 5:30 this morning and was out there
on the shakeout that took place today.
So she was in Oakland helping
with the office of emergency services.
She's a real trooper with this.
And these efforts have earned Lucy
the nickname "the Earthquake Lady."
She has sometimes been thought
of as the Earthquake Mother,
because she had to talk to
news reporters on camera
while holding one of her children.
She is trusted and beloved,
not just because she's a reassuring mom,
although that may be part of it,
but because she knows how to explain
complicated science to the public.
In 2007, I was part of
a multi-year, seven year
research project with a large team
led here at Berkeley by
professor Jack Maley,
who's here today, looking
at the risk reduction
in older concrete buildings.
We chose the city of Los
Angeles as a case study,
and we did extensive data collection
on the inventory of
buildings that were part of
our engineering analysis
of building performance
and part of our loss modeling.
This work became background
data when, in 2014,
Lucy Jones was asked to
serve on a special assignment
by the mayor of Los Angeles,
a science advisory
seismic safety committee
applying the results of
the shakeout scenario
and are using some of our
research in the background,
to look at the city's
older concrete buildings.
The planning, water backup systems,
the fire department building,
solar powered wireless networks.
A series of things.
And the wonderful news about this amazing
year that she spent building a coalition
of different political groups
in the city of Los Angeles
was that on October 9th, just last week,
Lucy celebrated a triumphant moment
as the legislation was passed
and required mandatory
earthquake retrofits
on 15000 buildings in Los Angeles.
As researchers, we were in
tears, we were so happy.
We can't tell you how important this is
and how much it meant.
But before I tell you
about her superb training,
let me tell you a story
about women in science.
Although her father, an engineer,
encouraged her interest
in math and science,
her high school guidance counselor said,
you shouldn't show you're good at math
'cause boys won't like you.
Even when she earned a perfect score
on the science aptitude test,
the counselor assumed that she cheated
and made her take the exam again
while the counselor watched.
Of course, she had a perfect score again.
Dr. Jones received a
bachelor of arts degree
in Chinese language and
literature, magna cum laude,
from Brown University in 1976.
At Brown, she also studied physics
and began to gravitate towards geophysics.
Needless to say, she was
the only woman in physics.
In 1981, she earned her
PhD in geophysics from MIT.
She is a fellow of the
American Geophysical Union,
member of the Resilient
America Round Table
of the National Academy of Science,
and previously served on the
California Seismic Safety Commission.
She has received numerous awards,
including meritorious service award
from the Department of Interior,
and the Ambassador Award from
the American Geophysical Union
for outstanding contributions
to policy and public service.
In early October, very recently,
she was awarded the Samuel J. Heyman
Service to American Medal
in citizens' services,
often referred to as the
Oscars of government service.
The Sammies recognize federal workers
who have made a notable impact
in the United States and around the world.
Despite being a woman in
a male-dominated field,
Jones has never asked for special
treatment because of her gender.
She never needed to.
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. Lucy Jones to Berkeley.
- Thank you Mary!
Well with that introduction.
I think I'm gonna have
to acknowledge that,
in fact, I think that there are times
where the gender has actually helped me,
especially in these public roles.
Because, you know, if
you ever have wondered
why you come and talk to a seismologist
after an earthquake anyway,
why do you care about which fault it is,
doesn't help you rebuild your building.
In fact I sort of, we give it a name,
we give it a number, we give it a fault,
we make it sound more
understandable, less frightening.
And I think people always feel better
when mommy tells them it's
okay than when daddy does.
So when a woman scientist gets up there,
we seem to be remembered more than the men
when they do exactly the same thing.
This talk is a bit of an experiment.
I haven't given a preliminary
version of this anywhere,
so you get to be my test subjects.
What I want to do is to actually
take what happened in Los Angeles
over the last year-and-a-half
and the really pretty
extraordinary experience
of trying to work that closely
with elected officials as a scientist,
and what insight I've been able to gain
about the nature of the interaction
and why we so often seem to
be talking past each other,
and try and take from that
some lessons for all of us as scientists
about what we, ways in which we could
do a more effective job of communicating.
Mary already told you
quite a bit about this.
Of course, in Southern California,
as up here, the scientists have been
doing a lot of work to understand
the nature of the risk.
Back in 2007 into 2008, we
created the shakeout scenario.
You probably all went
through the shakeout drill.
That was created to help people understand
the scientific model that
we had already created.
So we had hundreds of experts
trying to with the cutting edge science
from basic geology through seismology,
engineering, and the social sciences,
to get a comprehensive picture
of what the big earthquake would be like.
And the drill was actually created
to help people understand it.
And that's been out there and
we've been talking about it,
but it hasn't, you know,
there's only some
traction that it's gained.
A lot of emergency managers
used it for response,
but we weren't seeing people picking it up
as a way of understanding
how they could change the outcomes,
you know, that we weren't trying to do it
to say how bad it's gonna be.
We were trying to say how bad it could be
and why don't we not get there.
So we've been hoping to get more traction
on how to use the information
to stop the losses.
And then, in a large part actually,
because of the peer
study and the concrete,
well, it was only a mix of it.
Because of what's been
going on in San Francisco,
we went and approached
the mayor of Los Angeles.
We wanted to tell him about
the CAPSS Project in San Francisco,
which has been a decade-long effort
since the anniversary
of the 1906 earthquake,
the centennial, to really try
and bring people together.
We wanted to get something
similar going in Los Angeles.
And we had the meeting set up,
and the Los Angeles
Times ran a bit article
about the concrete buildings
and the whole peer study
that came out two days before the meeting,
which had been already set
for a couple of months.
It did affect the nature
of the discussions.
We had a little more focus
on what we were trying to talk about.
So the mayor was very interested
and a big piece of this, I have to say,
is really Mayor Garcetti having
the intelligence to understand the issues
and the confidence to take them on.
We've had previous elected officials
with one or the other,
and you really need to
have them both in place
to get action on a
difficult project like this.
What we ended up negotiating
was me actually spending
the year at City Hall,
which is about as different
a place from Cal Tech
as any place I can imagine.
I've spent my whole career
on campus at Cal Tech
where, I think even more
than this institution,
I don't have to worry about somebody
trying to look at me, let
alone try to talk to me.
And to go down to City Hall
and have people talking to me all the time
was an interesting experience.
But I'd like to take
this and look at some of
what happened here and how
I came to understand it,
and where it took us.
Just remind you that, you
know, we set these goals,
looking at what all the
earthquake issues are.
We wanted to protect the
lives of our citizens,
we wanted to improve
our ability to respond,
and make sure we were ready for recovery.
Well, these have been our
goals for a long time, right?
That hadn't changed.
What's changed is how we've
been able to respond to it.
And here's a quick list of
what the mayor's plan is.
It's extremely comprehensive,
addressing multiple areas of problems
with the built environment,
particularly old buildings,
and the mandatory retrofit
of soft-first story,
concrete, and excessive damage.
Buildings that are badly
damaged in an earthquake
have to be strengthened
and not just repaired.
Those are the ones that were wrapped up
into one ordinance that
passed last Friday,
a really big deal.
The voluntary rating
system, it's voluntary,
it doesn't require inspection.
Both of these have already been in place.
Most of these other items
are underway and getting started.
So it's been a, it's a huge project,
it's comprehensive and it's
more than I thought I was
gonna get going into City Hall.
So why?
What did we do differently this time?
What I wanna do is start with some
sort of basic things of thinking about
what the scientific process is
and how that compares with the way
the rest of the world works.
I don't know how many of you watch the,
what is it, xkcd cartoons.
The difference between
normal people and scientists,
the question of, with the science,
we don't think that coincidence
is automatically causality.
And in fact, I think you can put this,
that scientists actively reject stories.
Stories give you the wrong answer, right?
You go through this
situation and who knows
whether or not it was
really connected to that.
You have to test it over and over again.
The scientific process is the process
of making sure you are
not misled by a story,
that you go to your statistics
and you work out all of the details.
And in fact, I'm gonna do this to people.
How many of you are
scientists in the room?
Okay, definitely the majority.
So you have a pretty good idea
of how the scientific method works,
and it's not what your kid tends
to get taught in fourth grade, right?
You tend to notice something that happens.
You actually wonder whether it's
a coincidence or coincidental,
and you go and set up tests for it.
You come up with a model that you think
would explain that pattern
that's actually consistent with
the rest of the physics that you do.
You make predictions from the model
and you test the predictions.
Only after all of this do you
present it to your colleagues
and you make sure you explain
all of this along the way,
and your colleagues then go
and rip you to shreds, right?
This is a core piece also
of the scientific process.
That's the point of peer review,
it's to keep you from fooling yourself.
You may have thought you avoided
that story that misled you.
Your colleagues have the
job of making sure of that.
And this affects quite a bit about
how we go about communicating
with each other.
Because, as colleagues, our job
is to attack our colleagues.
It is to find the
weaknesses in the argument.
And we get taught this in grad school.
So we never ever give the answer first.
You know you're gonna be
pulled apart by your colleagues
if you've given the answer already.
Before you say what your result is,
you make sure you explain
the full background,
how you laid out the experiment,
all the uncertainties that you considered,
and only then do you give the result.
Because otherwise, your colleagues
are gonna get that result
and immediately jump to
ideas of why it's wrong.
So you don't communicate that way.
You always start with
the previous information
and work your way down
and give your result as the last thing.
This is classically the opposite
of the way most of the
rest of the world operates,
and especially journalists.
When you read a newspaper article,
they start with the result,
then they give you a
bit of why this matters,
and only when you get down
to the bottom of the article,
for the few people who make
it all the way through,
do they give you that background
information to set the context.
So when we go and communicate this way,
we've got half of the
people listening to us
who have stopped listening
before we ever get to the result.
This is, I think, really,
you've got the core issue, I think,
and how our communications
tend to fall apart
is right in here.
And there's a lot of other
things that fall out of it.
If we go ahead and look at
it in a bit more detail,
there's so many different ways
in which we differ
between the way you handle
scientific arguments or
scientific expression,
and the way journalists do it,
which is essentially the way
most of the rest of the world does it.
And part of this is writing.
This was actually done up as an exposition
on how differently scientists
and journalists write.
But it really can also
go into how we speak.
And when we talk about our results,
we're going to always
give our evidence first.
We're always gonna talk
about the uncertainties.
We always try to make sure
that there's a logical argument.
And we think that people
make their decisions
on logical arguments, which
also, in general, isn't true.
Another fundamental difference between
scientists and the rest of the world
is we live in uncertainty.
If it's already understood,
it is no longer interesting.
Nobody's doing research on
things that are well-understood.
That's not what we wanna talk about,
it's not what we wanna thing about.
We think about what we don't know.
But when we're looking at what it is
that people need to have from us,
they want to know what we do know,
the part that we're no
longer caring about.
And again, when we talk about our results,
we're gonna make sure we explain
what the uncertainties are,
and people, non-scientists,
often hear that as what we don't know.
And in fact, I'll get to a
little more detail on this later,
but there's a very significant issue
when we deal with earthquakes,
of how afraid people are of earthquakes,
that really is out of proportion
to the risk that they pose.
And when you look at what
makes people afraid of things,
uncertainty increases fear.
If somebody says, you know,
we know exactly what could happen,
that is less frightening to most people
than not knowing what might come through.
And so when we're communicating
in crisis situations,
it is a time when people particularly
want certainty from us, right?
And it's very tempting to
go and say we are certain.
Well scientists will tell
you all about the uncertainty
and leave people upset because of that.
The non-scientists tend
to move to certainty
even when it isn't there,
and say, don't worry,
we've got this handled.
And then if it turns out, in fact,
that they were wrong, it
actually becomes worse.
And in fact, there have been some studies,
you're gonna see some work,
Tim Sellnow and Deanna Sellnow,
they were at the University of Kentucky,
they just moved a month ago
to the University of Florida,
have done a lot of work in analyzing
how messages are perceived.
They're professors of risk communication.
And show a couple of different examples,
when you look at the number
of stories that are created.
So what we've got here is versus time,
number of stories, the
red's about swine flue,
the green is about vaccines,
and the blue is about
shortages of the vaccine.
So early on, people were saying,
don't worry, we've got
the vaccine, it's coming.
When, in fact, it didn't come,
then there was a whole
other set of stories
that developed about the shortages,
and got people much more
distressed about this
because they had been proved wrong.
Similar sort of data from media coverage,
I don't know if you remember
when there was salmonella in peanut paste.
And peanut paste turns out
to be put into all sorts of
different manufactured foods.
Originally they denied that it was there,
denied that there was a relationship.
When more information came out later,
you get this whole other surge
of extremely negative stories
because of the fact of being proved wrong.
And it's just to say that
the uncertainty we talk
about causes distress.
Turning it into certainty,
if you aren't gonna be
able to pull it off,
turns out to have a whole
other suite of problems.
If we go back to some of the more
fundamentals about science communication,
there's a lot of ways in which we can use
this thought about certainty versus
uncertainty in how we describe it.
So especially on the earthquake side,
people are often asking us if
we can predict earthquakes.
Which we can't, right?
There's nothing that's different
about the beginning of a six than a three,
so it's nothing, you know.
The threes are happening all the time,
so we don't see any changes
because the six is coming.
But people ask us that question,
and us literal-minded scientists
try to answer the question we're asked.
That's also one of the
mistakes that we tend to make.
Just as a general, answer the question
they should've asked instead
of the one they asked,
and you're often gonna
be a lot better off.
And if you ever listen to a politician,
you realize that they never get bothered
by the idea of answering a different
question than they were asked.
When you look at what
happens with earthquakes,
you see this a lot.
Because people ask us when
the next one's coming,
we can't answer it,
we've created a whole
series of probability maps
expressing the probability
that we would be having this.
We tend to do a lot of
miscommunication through this method.
We're always choosing
30 years to express it.
I don't know if you
know that we do 30 years
because it's the length of
most people's mortgages,
and therefore a timeframe on which
they are making financial decisions.
And we were asked to use 30 years
so we faithfully come
along and use 30 years.
And I would say probably half
of the population hearing this
thinks we know something about 30 years,
and that that's the
reason that we chose it.
So, in general, I'm not sure how much good
we've done with this,
because there's a lot
of misinterpretation that comes through.
And we also had the issue that the places
that don't have the
really high probabilities
say, oh, I'm okay.
I don't have a figure of this,
the classic one is San Diego.
They look at the red around
Los Angeles and San Francisco
and they're only yellow to orange.
Hey, we're good, we don't
have the problem that they do.
Any other state in the union
they'd be the most
dangerous city there was.
So again, what we are
communicating as we do this,
as we focus on the probabilities,
is we tend to increase the
feeling of uncertainty.
And what we're ignoring,
then, is the fact that,
in fact, we know exactly
what's gonna be happening
in the earthquake, we
just don't know when.
So by turning to scenarios,
so this is a scenario
we're working on right now
to get a much more detailed picture
of what we expect to happen
on the Hayward Fault.
We're calling it the Haywired Scenario,
'cause we're looking at the
impact on the digital economy,
as well as from the basic science of it.
By focusing on this, yeah,
we don't know when it is,
but we can tell you
what's gonna be happening.
And we have a lot of details
and a lot of certainty,
and by going to scenarios,
we have been able
to focus on what we know
rather than on what we don't know.
We increase the feeling of certainty.
There's an acceptance that
we don't know the time,
but we're able to focus on the fact
that, you know, time's not predicted,
a lot of other things are,
and a lot of other things
that can be useful.
Another significant issue
in these differences
is really how we treat
conflict and consensus.
To a journalist, the
story is in the conflict.
Just like to a playwright.
They look for where there's disagreement,
and that's where you hear the story.
So most journalist come in
and they hear an argument
between two people,
they think that's significant,
and in politics it is.
Of course, in science,
argument's what we do every day.
That is the scientific process,
where one person has a model
and the other person's
trying to break it down,
and the process by which we
find truth is the conflict.
So when we have a story
is when we have consensus.
When you've got everybody agreeing
and we stop being interested in it,
that's when you actually
have your scientific results.
And again, here's another problem.
Once it's settled and we've moved on,
that's really when we need to make sure
that it's being communicated
to the decision-makers.
So just the whole scientific process
does not encourage us to communicate
focused on the complete certainties.
It tends to get us focused
on the uncertainties,
which is what we want to do anyway.
Another difference, I think,
that's significant in this
is that the work in science is in details.
You might eventually be able to pull
everything back to a big unifying theory,
but to prove that something's true,
you need to get down
into the tiniest details,
be able to isolate one
factor from all others,
and be able to prove
what that one factor does
without the confusion
of the other factors.
So, in most sciences, we do our
work deep down in the weeds.
We are really focused
on separating it out.
And that also is gonna be how
we tend to talk with each other.
Because, to our colleagues, again,
it's where the interest is.
But in general, those details are not
what a policymaker needs to go
and make decisions about this.
So it's one more place where I see
our cultural differences
get in the way of the communication.
So if we sort of sum it up,
what the scientists are doing,
we're rejecting stories, we're
spending most of our time
dealing with uncertainties and
details about uncertainties,
and we expect to be arguing
with each other all the time.
That's what our process is.
So by comparison, what goes
on with an average person?
Richard Feynman had the classic
scientist address to it,
if they can understand it,
it must not be worth doing.
So there is an aspect of it that we
don't find any incentive to make our work
understandable to the more general person.
But compared to the scientists want,
they do respond to stories, those are very
important in making emotional connections.
They want to know what's known,
they don't want to know
what we don't know.
They wanna hear that there
isn't conflict, I miswrote that.
They want to know what's the consensus
rather than the conflict,
and the want the big picture,
they wanna understand
how it matters to them.
So we have some very
fundamental differences in here.
And a lot of them are tied
around emotional issues.
Decision-making is much more emotional
than most scientists would
like to know that it is.
You can make the logical argument
and they will use the logical argument,
but people need to feel how
they connect to that story
to want to take any action on it.
So then we need to get into
a lot of the ideas around how people
perceive their risks and respond to it.
And again, there's some really interesting
research that's been put together
in social sciences about
how people look at risk
and how it affects their decision-making.
Quite literally writing the book on it,
the book is called The Perception of Risk,
it's by Paul Slovic.
He's a psychologist out of
the University of Oregon
and much of the field is developed
from work from him and his students.
But they've been able to identify
several things that really increase
fear and how people respond
to emotional messages.
One of the biggest ones
is the involuntary.
We are quite happy to choose
things that are risky.
We drive on the freeway all the time,
and it's one of the most
dangerous things we do.
But we have the illusion
that we're in control,
'cause we're holding the steering wheel,
and we've chosen to do it.
So we are much more upset about
risks that are imposed on us
than when they come out of
things that we chose to do,
and earthquakes are sort of the ultimate
out-of-control experience,
and generate a lot of this.
We're also more afraid of things
that have the potential for
affecting a whole society,
potentially catastrophic,
increases our feeling
of it being dangerous.
An interesting on is, they call it
the dreadedness of the outcome.
If it's a really awful death,
it's somehow much worse to us
than a death that
wouldn't be that painful.
If we really wanted to
make our lives safer,
we'd shut down McDonald's, right?
We would be trying to deal with
the heart disease that we're facing.
But the idea of being
trapped in a downed building
and then the fire comes through,
I mean that's about as
awful as you can think of,
and again, earthquakes hit
a lot of those buttons.
The other thing is the idea
that it is invisible, unpredictable,
and unknown to science.
They all sort of tie together.
It increases that feeling
that we aren't in control of things.
And to the public, science,
it looks like we don't
understand earthquakes.
Partly because we get this focus
on when they're gonna happen,
which is the one part we really can't do.
It's also, though, that we don't do
a very good job of communicating
what we understand.
And I see this as a fundamental,
back to that answering the question
they should have asked idea,
the reporter comes in,
the earthquake happens,
they're faced with a scientist,
my god, how do I get this guy talking?
All right, what did you
learn in this earthquake?
'Cause that's a good way to get
a scientist to get talking, right?
The scientist takes it literally.
They wanna know what I
learned in this earthquake.
So they tell them what we didn't
know about the earthquake,
instead of replying, actually,
this was really predictable damage,
we got the, you know,
the buildings we thought were
gonna come down came down.
That's not the answer you give
to what did you learn in this earthquake.
So we tend to give messages
that we don't understand them,
and there's a very strong
perception in the public
that the damage is quixotic
and we don't know where it's gonna happen.
There's another issue that has
a pretty strong impact on how
people perceive our information,
and it's what's called numeracy.
You know, it's like literacy,
people who can understand numbers.
And so there's one fundamental issue
that there are a chunk of people
who are, who don't really
understand numbers.
They are not necessarily stupid people.
There are some very bright people
that are considered less numerate.
And highly numerate individuals
do do a better job of
handling probabilities.
You will often see in this
situation an overthinking.
Well I mean, come on,
10 percent in 30 years?
I think I'm fine, you know?
You can overanalyze some of the numbers.
But you also see that
the emotional impacts
have a much higher effect
on the people with low numeracy.
And it's something, you know,
there's actually been quite a bit
of research on how people handle this,
and it's not an obvious thing.
Like I said, it's not being stupid,
but there is a significant percentage
of the population that
does not process numbers
the way we think about it.
We also have discovered that even when,
even highly numerate
people can misinterpret,
they don't use the probabilities
when strong emotions are involved.
And so even the people who think
they're being very logical,
we will see with strong emotions
that there are extreme reactions
to something that would really
be a very low probability risk.
But if it's got a strong
emotion attached to it,
that doesn't really go through.
And I just had to add this other one,
'cause I find this really odd,
that even highly numerate people
respond differently to what's called
relative frequency instead
of to probabilities.
If you say something has a
one in 10 chance of happening,
people see it as being more likely
than when you say 10 percent.
Even people who understand numbers,
there is an emotional reaction.
They think it's tied to,
when you say one in 10,
you're focusing on that one,
you're focusing on things
that have a bad outcome.
Whereas a 10 percent chance is sort of
focusing on it not happening.
And it applies across the board,
however much education you've got
and what level of numeracy you've got.
We always see more compelling responses
when you use frequencies.
Which actually changed
some of my behavior,
'cause I sort of recognized
not everybody got it,
and I used to say, well you know,
there's a five percent chance
that this will be a four shock.
That means that it's a one in 20 chance,
95 percent chance that it won't happen.
And I would tend to give them
all of these different numbers,
some of them with relative frequency
and some with probabilities.
And that was probably a
really bad way of doing it,
because people hear
them differently enough,
it ends up confusing the messages.
Okay, let me go back then and say,
if we've got these sort of differences,
how are we trying to bridge the gaps?
And I think, there's a couple of ways
in which we've gone about doing this.
One is recognizing that our scientific
belief that logic is how
people make decisions,
we just needs to accept that
that's not true in a lot of people.
And especially in the elected environment,
they need to be responding
to the emotions of their constituents.
And that, the value-based judgment
is how it is going to be happening.
And if you wanna convince
an elected official
to take an action, you don't do it
by giving him numbers
and giving him the logic.
What you need to do is help them
be able to see how this action
or decision affects their world.
And one of the things that I've done
within the USGS over the last decade
is leading a program to develop
scenarios of various natural disasters.
We began with the shakeout scenario, here,
but we've also done ones of storms,
we've done ones with tsunamis.
As I said, we're moving up here now
into the Hayward Fault one.
And these scenarios serve
a couple of functions.
One of them is focusing on what we know
as opposed to what we don't know,
really being able to
concentrate on the impact
rather than the uncertainty
about what the time is.
The other thing we're doing, though,
is we're making a story.
And I didn't realize it at the time,
but as I look back, I'm realizing
the incredible importance
of that approach,
that a scenario is essentially
a scientifically-defensible story.
And in fact, that
scientifically-defensible part
is by far the hardest.
When we make one scenario,
we're picking on plausible outcome,
and the scientists tend to look at it
and go, but why'd you
make this assumption?
Why'd you make that assumption?
Don't you think this
could be what happened?
Don't you think we should be
doing this probabilistically?
And we have to say, you know,
this isn't trying to express
the true range of risk.
This is being plausible,
helping people understand
how the disaster fits in their
world and their decisions.
And we have to accept that,
when we make a scenario,
we are not going to be
getting that earthquake.
So many assumptions went
into creating shakeout.
That will not be the
earthquake that happens.
We are trying to say this
is a plausible earthquake,
it's the type of thing that
we need to be planning for,
but giving them that story
let's them see how it affects their world.
And one of the things
we did in this process
was move closer to storytelling
that I ever would've imagined
before we got into it.
And in fact, what I'm gonna show next,
this is actually, we took
all of the scientific
analysis for the shakeout scenario,
and we turned it not just
into a story, but a movie.
We are working in Southern California,
around the corner from Hollywood.
- [Narrator] It's a sunny
morning in Southern California.
Across the region, 7.5 million
people are busy at work.
Several hundred thousand of them
are commuting to jobs
in different counties,
far from where they live.
Over 200000 commuters work and reside
on opposite sides of
the San Andreas Fault.
Today, these families, and many others
across the region, will be separated.
1800 people will die.
53000 people will be injured.
And 213 billion dollars
in damage incurred.
It's 10:00 AM.
The largest earthquake to
hit Southern California
in modern times has just begun.
Some people react
appropriately, others don't.
In the intense shaking, nearly
1500 buildings collapse.
Infrastructure is severely compromised,
and 300000 buildings
suffer significant damage.
The rupture travels 200 miles northwest
along the San Andreas Fault.
Violent shaking, lasting as long
as two minutes in some areas.
Finally, the earthquake is over.
Many of the lifelines
of Southern California
have been disrupted.
A large number of people are
trapped in collapsed buildings.
Over 1600 fires start,
some turning into super conflagrations.
Millions of people are
trying to use their phones,
causing the system to become overloaded.
In the months ahead, there will be
tens of thousands of aftershocks.
Residents will struggle to
recover from the earthquake.
There will be no water
for weeks or months,
and no electricity.
Traveling from point to point
within the city will
be extremely difficult.
And 255000 people will be
displaced from their homes.
We are all in this together.
We will suffer the consequences
if we don't do our part right now.
How quickly life gets back to normal
after this disaster is up
to you and those around you.
Your level of personal preparedness
will determine your quality
of life after the quake.
It's a good idea to have
a fire extinguisher,
a first aid kit, and enough water
for each person in our household
to have at least one gallon
of water a day for three days.
Have an emergency plan.
Decide now where you will meet
your family after an earthquake.
Make sure there's a person out of town
you can contact to let your loved ones
know that you're okay.
Homeowners should be sure to bolt
their house to its foundation.
Consider whether earthquake insurance
makes sense for you as part
of your financial plan.
Even if you're not a homeowner,
you can secure your personal possessions
against earthquake damage.
Preparedness is not only for
the home but also for business.
Be sure that your company has emergency
plans for a major earthquake.
Empower yourself and your family.
Be prepared.
- Okay.
So, not the usual way in which
we usually publish our scientific results.
It has, however, gotten a
million hits on YouTube.
And it's gotten our message out
much farther than any other
thing that we could've done.
I'm getting close to wrapping up.
I wanna spend a moment,
it is shakeout day,
to look at some of the
other communication messages
we got out of the process
of creating shakeout,
and which ones of them work.
So we had a few different explicit tactics
that we developed as we
were creating shakeout.
We talked with the social scientists
and we came up with certain objectives
as we went and put the pieces together.
Let me just go through them.
Consistent messaging
is a big piece of this.
When people hear the same
message from multiple sources,
it is more reassuring,
it increases that feeling of certainty
than when you get different
people saying different things,
that greatly reduces
the level of certainty.
So we made the decision,
of all of the different
earthquake safety proponents,
that we would settle on the same message,
we would focus on drop cover hold on,
and that we would, and then plus,
take one more step, do one other thing.
And we went out through multiple media.
We bought, some of us bought advertising,
had a lot of different ways
in which we went about it,
and we shared the messaging
and made sure that it was consistent,
creating something called the
Earthquake Country Alliance
in Southern California, it's now been
working out more nationwide.
Another piece of it is
visual reinforcement.
People are more likely to do
what they see other people doing.
This was one of the reasons
we focused on the drill,
because how do you see people
preparing for an earthquake?
That's a pretty abstract sort of thing.
Whereas looking like
an idiot under a table
and trying to not have
your butt sticking out,
I've done this too many years,
it's a very defined visual, and it says,
oh, these people are
thinking about earthquakes.
So we are, that is part of it,
but it's a generalized picture,
not just the drill itself,
that you are taking this on.
So drop cover hold on, we actually got
all of these graphics that were donated
during the process of keeping that going.
We also focused on
making this the biggest,
you know, a big media event.
How do we get that visual image?
We were trying, you know,
we explicitly took on things
like the quake cottage
and things that were visual
to get it to show up on TV,
to try and encourage that visual process.
Another aspect is that people only
come to the decision to do something
by talking about it with
people they care about.
This is apparently a
pretty important piece.
It is very rare for somebody to just go,
oh okay, I understand this
risk, I'm gonna do this.
They usually need to take a process
that gets them from the
acceptance to the action,
and being able to talk about
it makes a big difference.
In the drill, what we did is focusing
on trying to have the drill happen
in all of the different
entities at the same time.
The reason we're doing this
is to encourage people to talk about it,
so that the kid comes home from school
and says, mommy I had an
earthquake drill today,
and mommy's like, oh, I
had one at work today too,
and daddy's, yeah, so did I.
And maybe you get some
family discussion going.
At a different level, this is really
the process that happened
by me moving into City Hall.
One of the reasons it had happened
where I think it hasn't in a more,
you know, without such
close collaboration,
is because you needed
to sit and talk about it
and make it seem real and make it part
of the discussion to get it to happen.
But then I think one of the other
really important things that they said
is that we shouldn't be
just presenting the problem.
And this is one of the core issues,
and I think it's gonna,
it plays into a lot of other
scientific communication,
that we as scientists are only comfortable
talking about the things
that we do, right?
I'm an expert on seismology,
I need to be talking about that
and not about the engineering issues.
And especially, even if I'm willing
to pretend I'm an engineer,
or at least talk about what my
engineering colleagues have done,
the policy part really feels
like it belongs to someone else.
But it's been really clear
that when you present the
problem without a solution,
you don't encourage action,
you encourage anxiety.
And in fact, some more
work from the Sellnows.
They expressed it as this,
they called it the idea model,
that internalization,
explanation, and action
all have to be part of
any crisis communication.
And that if you don't
have all three pieces,
you often make it actually worse
and less likely that
people will take action.
They did a lot of different studies.
I decided I'd just throw this up here
and say, yes, there's
numbers behind all of this,
as they tested various groups of people.
But what you get down to is
if you only tell people
what they should do
and the science of it,
but you don't tell them
how it relates to them
and why they individually
should care about it,
you generate indifference.
If you convince them
that it matters to them
and you tell them why, what's going on,
but you don't tell them
what to do about it,
they actually test out with
diminished knowledge and confidence
and less likely to take action.
You have to put all three of them together
to actually see an increase in action
and working towards these things.
So, what does this have
to do with climate change?
Obviously this isn't really
a talk about climate change,
I'm sorry if you got
teased in here on that
and we aren't getting to it.
But my experiences out of
that earthquake process,
and I feel like I'm
coming up with results,
but let's think about it, how it applies
to what is going on in climate change.
And I think there's two big pieces,
and you've heard me saying
it over and over again today.
One is our focus in on uncertainty.
When we're talking about this,
we all know it's happening.
What we are interested in as
scientists is the details.
How much of it is human-induced?
Exactly where are the models working out?
What exactly is gonna be
the result for California?
How much extra rain are we gonna get?
We focus on all the things
that we don't have the answer to.
The absolutely basic, you can
do it in a high school lab,
that when you put heat and you have
extra carbon dioxide, you trap more heat,
and you take out the carbon
dioxide, you trap less heat,
it's so simple, we don't talk about it.
And yet that absolute
basic and being certain
is the message that people need to hear.
But wait a minute, we've just told them
that all the scientists agree,
and where the hell did this number
97 percent of scientists come from?
Sometimes I really wonder who
those other three percent are.
But that's telling people
you aren't smart enough
to make your own mind,
you need to believe it because
all the right people tell you to.
And I think this ties back
to a pretty fundamental aspect
of how we treat science education.
We educate people in science
to find the future scientists.
Go listen to the discussion.
We need to have more STEM education,
'cause look at all those STEM careers.
We never say everybody needs
to be a science researcher.
And I don't mean understand science facts.
We sort of treat science the way
people in the Middle Ages treated reading.
Reading was for a specialist.
You didn't need to do it yourself.
Right?
If you needed somebody
to read or write for you,
you went and got a
scribe to do it for you.
Even the kings didn't write.
You got your information by hearing what
the priest was telling you in the pulpit.
But with the advent of the printing press,
we started really changing that,
and within, you know, not that long,
after the advent of the printing press,
you needed to be able to read yourself
to participate in the social discourse.
You could still get a job,
but you weren't really part of society.
And we're treating science
the same way we used to treat reading.
If you need to get a
scientific analysis done,
get a specialist to do it for you.
And you know, most of us in this room
have made jobs out of that
and made careers out of doing that,
and we don't really expect
others to be doing it as well.
But I would suggest that,
in the internet era,
that the whole digital revolution
is changing societal need
for scientific analysis,
that with the removal of the constraints
of the cost of print and ink,
absolutely any information gets published
and is accessible to everyone.
We no longer have an editor telling us
what's fit to print, what
you should be listening to.
Absolutely everything,
including the complete nonsense,
is out there available to people.
And individuals now need
to make their own decisions
about what information
is worth listening to.
That is the scientific skill.
That's what scientific analysis is.
How to look at data and
understand its significance
and understand the implications of it.
And really, to handle the flood
of information in the internet era,
everyone needs some level
of scientific analysis.
And if people in general had those skills,
we wouldn't be having this
discussion about climate change,
we wouldn't be saying believe it
because all the scientists believe it.
It would be so blazingly obvious.
So I think that's one big aspect,
that we really need to take a hard look,
as scientists, at how
we are educating others,
and how do we take these skills
and not restrict them solely to the people
who are gonna become our clones,
but really recognize it's a
skill that everybody needs.
The second issue that I think we're facing
with climate change is that
we have done the classic thing of
we've told people but the problem is
without giving them a solution.
When scientists get up there
and talk about climate change,
we talk about all the
things that are going wrong,
and you gotta deal with it.
And most people, I've actually started
sort of checking this out with people,
and we should probably do a more
statistical analysis of this,
I am astonished how
many intelligent people
who accept climate change,
your general Californian,
believes that the only way to deal with it
is giving up our current life.
It seems like the solution has gotta,
we've gotta give up fuels, fossil fuels,
doesn't that mean we have
to give up our computer,
how are we gonna manage
to have the life we want,
and we really don't wanna
give up the life we want.
So we move back from thinking about it.
Yeah, it's happening, but I
guess we'll have to adapt.
Or I don't wanna think it's happening
because I don't wanna deal
with the consequences.
And I would suggest, if we want
to get action on climate change,
we need to give people something
concrete and positive to do.
When I look at it, I tie it, actually,
to the rather fundamental
issue that oil is finite.
There's various versions of this model
that show oil production versus time
and how it's expected to go.
And as we have, you know,
the graph shifts at times.
When we started fracking,
we got a lot more versions of oil.
We have deepwater drilling
that's able to go on.
As we make explorations, we've been able
to delay the running out of fossil fuels.
But that does not mean we
won't run out of fossil fuels
any more than avoiding an accident
somehow makes you immortal, right?
There is still only so much oil out there.
And at some point, and whether it's 2050
or 2100 or sometime,
we will be out of oil.
And when that happens, we will
either no longer have energy,
or we will have renewable energy.
And I'm pretty sure,
we're pretty smart people,
we will have renewable energy.
So that's where we're
going to be eventually.
And the only question is
how much social disruption
and how much ecologic
disruption we take to get there.
So there's a really clear, obvious answer
to what we do about climate change,
and that's, we vest a whole lot of money
in renewable resources,
because whoever develops
the really efficient renewable energy,
they're gonna be ruling the world
when we get to this world without oil.
Why don't we want that to be us?
And we can take that message
and combine it with climate change
and say, there's your solution,
and it's good for the long-term
health of our country.
Let's take positive action
and move in that direction.
And I think, you know,
why I was successful in L.A.,
it was having a clear story
of what the problem was,
and tied it to a solution.
You take these actions and
you are protecting our city.
We need to do the same
thing with climate change.
People don't want a
world that falls apart.
They don't want it so badly
that if we don't give them a solution,
they need to believe that
it isn't gonna end up there.
And to be able to believe it
they need to see the path forward.
So thank you.
- [Audience Member] I
wonder how much of your talk
we could also summarize by the
words of visual imagination.
You mentioned that
scientists think one way,
journalists think the other way,
but in my experience, every scientist
I've ever known thinks visually,
and when I read
newspapers, it's very clear
that the journalists are verbal thinkers.
And there's a big big difference.
You mentioned numeracy, and again,
everyone I know thinks of numbers
or visualizes numbers
in a sorta visual way,
but yet those who call themselves
not so numerate, or whatever one uses,
are actually usually people
who do not think visually.
And then you also mentioned the
process of science education
where we select those who
will be future scientists.
Basically, our science
education right now,
it's selecting those who think visually
and excluding other people.
And I think you also
pointed to an ideal world
in which the general public
is kind of scientifically literate,
and I would venture that that
ideal world you described
is actually where everybody
is somewhat visually imaginative,
that everybody still has
the same visual imagination
that they had when they
were five-years-old
before they learned to read.
You pointed out Gutenberg
and how Gutenberg
changed the world and changed reading
from being something that
only a select few did
to something that most people could do,
and I would say using visual imagination
might be the equivalent of your Gutenberg,
that if we get everybody
to use visual imagination,
then what we call scientific thinking
would not be the world
of just a select few.
- I would agree that all
of these things, I think,
would help, and I do think
visualization is part of it.
I do think the storytelling part
is one of the biggest
things that can be visual.
But we know as scientists
we have to reject it,
and yet the users, we could
really use more light than this,
the users need the stories
for the emotional connection.
Yeah.
- So in stories we might
set up a heroes journey,
and pretty quickly we're gonna
get into good guys and bad guys.
Is that gonna work in a case like this?
Do we need to talk about
good guys and bad guys?
- I don't think we should be talking
about good guys and bad guys,
and I think that that's actually
been one of the problems,
and whereas just going, here's a solution
that makes a difference, and you tie
a concrete solution and
an action you can take,
it's gonna be a lot easier
to acknowledge it and move forward.
- Hi, great talk.
I was really, the last thing
you talked about was the action,
and you gave a very big example,
that we can change our entire system.
But I'm wondering if it wouldn't be
at least as effective to give people,
like, maybe even solutions that,
as a person who really
cares about global warming,
you feel like, oh my
god, this is pathetic,
but if your goal is to get someone
to begin to believe the science,
then like, planting a tree in their yard
might actually help them
believe global warming science.
- I think you have to have
some connection already made
to get, I mean I don't
think that it's wrong
to go for those small actions,
giving people individual
things that they can do,
and I think one of the problems
with climate change is it's so large,
it is a hard thing to
make that connection.
None of the solutions are
absolute, let's put it that way.
But I think that these
ideas that you tie solutions
to the problem, you give actions,
it makes it easier to
process the information.
And you can say, we've
got these bigger ones
and we can take these smaller
actions along the way.
- At the risk of being disdained for this,
I honestly do wanna know
about educating scientists,
because as a science writer,
I have worked with
scientists most of my life,
and when I have individually
talked to small groups
of, often, PhDs and former academics
who are now in the private sector,
I'm not credible to them
until I tell them about
my science training.
And then all of a sudden,
okay, you're okay,
you're a geologist, that's good.
No I'm not, I was a mediocre
geologist, I'm a superb writer.
So what I have done with small groups
is talk to them about, you know,
because I was in marketing eventually,
how we perceive information.
And I mentioned, each time, five traits
of very highly-trained scientific minds
versus some of the negatives
in terms of marketing
for the highly-trained scientific minds.
You know, the fact that
you go to negatives first,
and you're presenting that to others.
After that, I asked every single one
of the listeners to please write down
all the positives and all the negatives.
Not one person remembered
all the positives.
Almost all of them
remembered all the negatives.
I think that has to do with
their critical thinking skills.
Because they are going
to the negatives first,
they don't understand the filters.
So my concern is about mutual respect.
I want to bring that to both parts,
both the fear that people won't
understand the scientists,
scientists are disdaining others
- Well I think that that's sort of what
I'm trying to say, is that
the training of scientists,
what's needed to do the science
of rejecting the stories,
of being critical of each other,
are processes that we
have to do as scientists,
and what I'm asking is that I think
that we need to acknowledge
that those can't,
that's not the way the
rest of the world thinks
and it can get in the
way of our communication.
So not give it up, because we
have to do it as scientists
or we aren't gonna get the right answer,
but we need to recognize
that it is not the way
much of the rest of
the world communicates,
and we need to take that into account
when we're trying to do it,
and not say other people are wrong
for not doing it that way.
But I think helping everyone understand
the nature of peer review
and critical data analysis
is gonna help as well.
- So this is fascinating,
thank you for talking about it.
I think the difference in
the way that scientists
and normal folks, as it were,
communicate is relatively large.
I come out of a religious community,
and especially, I think,
the way we think about the way
that global warming gets tied up
with narratives around
creation, especially for,
like, conservative or
evangelical Christians.
And so my question is just kind of,
their world view and
their approach to ecology
is so embedded in a particular narrative
about the way the world
works, and is there,
do you know if there's any
work that's being done around that?
Or how can we communicate with folks
whose entire story that they tell
about reality differs so drastically?
- Well, yeah, I can't solve everything.
I would just say that that,
it's a temptation that we need to avoid
to think that that is the
definition of religious.
I would rather say that that is
the definition of a very small subset.
And if you've got people who insist
that there is no data and that
the world is 6000-years-old and that's it,
and anything that says
otherwise is God testing you,
that's a logically consistent model
that's incompatible with what
it is we're trying to do.
But I think that, you know,
there's a whole lot of other range,
and I will say, I'll end
on a controversial note,
how about I do that?
Is that one other difference
between scientists and journalists,
scientists believe in reality.
Our science is an
attempt to model reality.
We always know we don't have it right.
Every new science advance is
disproving something else,
and we know that eventually,
our models are gonna be supplanted.
So eventually, so we know we're wrong.
But we are trying to do
the best possible job,
and we know there is right and wrong
and there is something real.
And I will say that that's part of
the religious worldview too,
is that there is reality,
Different ways of understanding
and different parts of reality
that perhaps aren't reflected
in the data in the physical world,
but they believe that there is truth.
To a journalist, there's often not truth.
There's always the
other side of the story.
And they don't accept the concept
that something can just be right.
And I think that's another time
that when you always have to
find the other side of the story,
instead of saying,
actually, this is just true,
or even to accept the concept
that something can be true,
is a challenge, and I think that sometimes
there are bigger differences between
scientists and journalists than between
scientists and people of faith.
So on that note, thank you.